last night sunday night football yeah
this was the stunner and i don't want to
say we should have seen it coming chris
but maybe we should have seen it coming
i don't know you can't really factor in
patrick mahomes with an ankle injury i
was saying earlier that
all the things that we are accustomed
now
to seeing from patrick mahomes the
effortless nature with which he plays
the freedom the looseness that's all
premised on him being 100 yeah you take
away any of his physical ability his
ability to move his ability to throw his
ability to do the things he does and
it's more it's more of a chore it feels
like he's laboring he can still do it
yeah but it's harder to do it and he
wasn't able to pull off enough points
last night to beat the call well yeah
and then okay like you're saying there's
the home sector and then let's let's add
in a few other things oh our starting
left tackle is not there oh our best
receiver maybe in football is not there
oh
our other receiver that we're paying
like odell beckham jr sammy watkins is
injured and hurts his hamstring early in
the game so you can't forget those
circumstances let alone chris jones
getting hurt later in the game i mean
there was just a lot of issues and the
cults are not a pushover and the colts
played the game the right way i mean i
think that's one thing i think we talked
about and we feared a little bit and we
talked about it on sunday night football
last night a little was if the colts can
control the line of scrimmage on the
offensive side of the ball and kind of
go on those you know clock eating type
drives yeah that's hard for a high
octane offense like the kansas city
chiefs and the colts played the game uh
just right the chiefs had limited uh
possessions in both halves really
because of some of these long drives and
that that really was the difference in
the game more than not yeah 45 rushing
attempts for the colts on sunday night
180 yards the colts had the ball 37
minutes and 15 seconds 22 minutes 45
seconds for the chiefs wow
you said last week that is what they
need to do but neither of us believe
they could do it yeah slow the game down
right keep patrick holmes on the
sidelines minimize the chief's
possessions but even then we thought
yeah i thought you're still not gonna be
able to do it right i still thought with
some of the the the injuries that the
colts have had to overcome on defense
you know secondary guys just getting
healthy on the on the defensive line i
didn't think they would be able to pull
it off because i still thought kansas
city would jump out to an early lead and
put them in a position maybe where they
can't be
patient with the run game but limited uh
you know limited possessions you know
you have a three and out in the first
half and then lesean mccoy fumbles as
you're driving on a nice screen play i
mean hey that's all it takes in the nfl
you know the colts i mean the chiefs are
a really really good team but when
you're missing some of your best players
who are being paid the most amount of
money on your team and then you get some
injuries and having mistakes in a few
games i don't care who you are i mean
you're going to be in strugglesville as
far as trying to win a football game and
let's not forget you know with the
cult's coming off a a bad loss last week
at home they're going oh my gosh we're
looking at two and three if we lose this
there's a desperation factor and of
course the chiefs are feeling good about
themselves going into the football game
and that always plays a an aspect in it
as well before mahomes banged up the
ankle he had a couple of throws that
would make us revise our top five left
from last night and the best plays
here's one of them oh no that's not one
of them sorry no no no that would
definitely not be one of them got to
throw it but but he had a few of those
plays that we are just so
accustomed to we just take it for
granted yeah but you you tweak that
ankle a little bit and he can't do the
things that we're used to seeing after
the game he explained to reporters how
the colts went about slowing down the
kansas city offense here's patrick
mahomes
they played good defense i mean they
played man coverage they they rushed
with four people and and they and they
found ways to get pressure and to cover
long enough and so
for us i mean
detroit did it last week uh new england
did in the playoffs i mean we're going
we're not the beat man coverage at the
end of the day and we got the guys to do
it so now it's about just going out
there and executing whenever whenever
teams present it to us the colts have
been using a lot of zone before last
night but they realize this is what you
need to do and that's how you coach
winning football if you're frank reich
or any other successful coach in the nfl
you come up with a game plan based upon
the opponent that you're facing and you
can't be
too proud to ignore what has worked
elsewhere right oh our system will work
no what works is man sure don't try to
play zone against these guys take them
man for man especially without tyree
kill sammy watkins exits maybe you can
slow these guys down no matter what
patrick mahomes is doing that that's
ultimately i think what leads them to go
okay we can play man-to-man against
these guys when you go no tyree kill you
go okay maybe we can dabble in a little
bit more man than usual then he goes oh
no sammy watkins let's get up in their
face let's take away some of these plays
our pass rush is pretty good they've had
some issues protecting lately you know
let's see if we can you know make
mahomes pat the ball one two extra times
and try to get there um but this is this
is one of the things i worry about with
the chiefs their ability to be versatile
and come up with other ways to win
football games it's just like we saw
last year if the air attack isn't you
know on you know full steam ahead then
it's kind of like oh man what are they
going to do they can't really run the
ball they don't have a great short
passing offense you know i mean do we
really ever see a lot of easy short
completions for patrick williams no we
don't so you have that and then you go
on to the defense
i mean you know again the defense i know
they lit up 19 points last night but did
you ever think they were really going to
make a key stop in any of the big
moments
absolutely not right i mean you just
never felt that way so that's where you
worry the chiefs are built to outscore
you out pointing you uh put the pressure
on you on the on the scoreboard and when
they don't have those you know players
and key aspects of their football team
it really shows and we got to give
credit to the colts for pulling it off
it's one thing to say this is what we
think we can do it's another thing to
actually do it here's frank reich the
coach of the colts talking about the
victory after the game
we've been saying that the whole
offseason we've been saying it the whole
year this is this is what we've
this is what we want to define us we
want it all to start up front when when
we got here
you know with chris two years ago and we
started talking about what we wanted to
build this is the kind of team we wanted
to build and uh
that was put on display tonight on both
sides of the ball
and who would have ever dreamed about a
month and a week or two ago when andrew
luck abruptly retires that was one of
the first things i thought of oh my gosh
we got a prime time game on nbc week
five colts chiefs oh what do you do now
you play the game right and maybe the
colts win and they did win yeah no they
did win and they did it with a you know
a team effort and jacoby brissett really
playing well for the most part of the
night i mean only he really had the one
bonehead mistake other than that you
know just manage the game didn't let the
game get out of hand at any chance i
think he did a good job of realizing
what the game was going to be like in
its entirety after the first quarter oh
okay our defense has a little bit of a
feel for them you know we're going to be
able to run the ball there's no point in
me taking any big chances but
frank reich can't talk about him enough
i mean they just always seem to be
resilient when their backs against the
wall and uh that that speaks to frank
reich and his ability and as a coach and
a leader the colts weren't the only team
to rebound from a tough week four loss
to go into a hostile territory and beat
a good team the packers pulled the same
thing off earlier in the day on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports